[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie I got a bunch
of requests to do a breakdown of the new
Game of Thrones prequel plot and cast
there's a whole bunch of new details
that we have about it that helps us sort
of place what's going on and where we're
going to be visiting bunch of new
locations that we never been to on the
TV show as you would expect but that had
been mentioned in the book several times
or by other characters on the TV show
we'll do a new round of the Song of Ice
and Fire book giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video first big thing
they confirm the rest of the core main
cast there'll be many other people that
they'll announce as they get ready to
start filming but these are just gonna
be the most important characters when
the first season picks up we already
know about Josh White House who sort of
reads as a Stark in his features and
complexion then there's Naomi Watts who
could either be a Lannister or she could
wind up being a Valyria but based on the
context of how George or Martin & HBO
have talked about Valyria as it relates
to what's going on during this time
period of the prequel series which is
actually closer to 5,000 years ago I'll
talk about that in a second because
previously we thought it was 10,000
years now it's more like 5,000 years
which actually changes things quite a
bit
but based on what they're saying and the
types of characters Naomi Watts is known
for playing it just seems more likely
that she winds up playing a Lannister
but the rest of the main cast is as
follows Naomi a key who's gonna be in
Star Wars Episode nine you may not have
seen a lot of her stuff but I think that
the role that she's playing was
originally offered to Leticia right from
Black Panther so if you seen Leticia
Wright's work and the types of
characters she plays that's kind of what
they're going for in this character I'll
talk about where she's probably from in
a second because a lot of those new
characters that they announced look like
they're either from lower continental
Essos so throws potentially Valyrian
Peninsula Summer Isles basilisk Isles
places like that there's a whole region
a planet oast that we have not spent a
lot of time in the next one is Danny's
golf a lot of people are theorizing that
she's going to be another Brienne type
sort of defying gender tropes because
most of the characters this actress is
known for playing our Brienne types or
LGBTQ characters but she looks like
she's somewhere from mid continental
Westeros just because she doesn't have
stark features and she doesn't have the
Arabic features that a lot of the
Dornish
people have from sub-continental
Westeros Sheela Tim and Ivana Jeremiah
the next big - they look like they could
either be summer Islanders they could be
from so throws or obviously somewhere
near the lower Valyrian Peninsula I'll
talk about ghiscari Empire because the
old ghiscari Empire ruled most of Essos
during this time period but for the most
part the way George R Martin writes the
history of Planet os-- is that like
certain genetic features and races do
come from very specific places but like
myths and I for instance comes from the
Summer Isles along with grey worm they
were sold into slavery so that's why
they spent most of their time in and
around ash - pores slavers Bay in that
region just because that's where they
were sold into slavery even though they
originally worked from that region most
people will probably remember georgie
henley as lucy Pevensey from The
Chronicles of Narnia she's in her early
20s now but she just seems like another
stark character just because of her
features so like another small
precocious Arya Stark type hopefully
then we have Alex Sharpe who just based
on his features looks like he could be
from pretty much anywhere in Westeros
northern region like the Eyrie or near
Winterfell or down near the storm lands
but then we have Toby regbo who you all
probably remember his young Dumbledore
from fantastic beasts that looks like
he's the second coming of Loras so he
could be from the reach he could be
another Lannister Jamie Campbell Bower
who you remember is young Grindelwald
from fantastic based a lot of Harry
Potter actors that are joining the
series is one of the few people I think
you know based on his facial structure
in the color of his hair leans a little
bit more into the Valyrian territory but
he could also be a Lannister as well
George R Martin has talked a little bit
about what's going on with Valyria
around this period and he's actually
written about it before but like I said
he adjusted the time period that had
been set during he acknowledged that in
the books most maesters quote that era
being around 10,000 years ago right
before the construction of the wall but
then George art Martin also said later
that there's a lot of conflicting
evidence and maesters can't agree
amongst themselves about when certain
things happen during history so that's
his and HBO's way of retro actively sort
of smudging the timeline scrunching it
down a bit and say no it's closer to
5,000 years ago but for the most part
we're talking about the events of the
long night so they're not necessarily
changing a lot of the big historical
events that we know about because we
do have a loose timeline for Game of
Thrones that goes back about 10,000
years they're just adjusting when some
of those things happen in condensing a
lot of stuff the reason why I think part
of the series is going to take place in
and around the Valyrian Peninsula the
Summer Isles and so Thoreau's is because
obviously the complexion of some of the
characters that they've cast but also
they're filming part of the pilot
episode in the Canary Islands and if
you've never been there this is what it
looks like very tropical very humid
which is freeze Summer Isles saw throws
Valyrian Peninsula looks a little bit
different we saw it a little bit during
season 5 on the TV show when Tyrion and
Jorah were just paddling their way
through remember during this period
though most of Valyria is thought of is
a group of sheep herders in and around
the 14 flames the Valyrian freehold
hasn't risen they haven't found out how
to tame dragons yet so it's still very
early in their lifespan which at that
time the ghiscari Empire was the
dominant political force in Essos so
they'll probably be a big presence on
the TV show but whatever they're going
to be doing with these characters a lot
of it seems like it's going to be taking
place at least initially down in this
region as for what's going on in
Westeros there are actually two options
because George RR Martin's said that
they would not be rehashing stuff that
we're already seeing on the TV show and
because they were calling the series the
long night and that's the same night
king that they're trying to defeat now
it would be a big rehash of stuff that
we saw in the TV show if we're watching
his origin story again so we could wind
up seeing them at the tail end of the
long night as the walls being
constructed because we didn't see
dragons in and around that fight when
they were trying to defeat the night
King the first time so it could still
explain how George R Martinez say no we
haven't tamed dragons yet that's still
really early stages but the really big
geopolitical Wars that could be going on
in the background around this time
obviously besides the long night because
George Omar has been talking about it
for so much is the war between the
children in the first men and then
ghiscari Wars happening in Essos so a
lot of that stuff does coincide and then
you have the rise of the balerion
freehold in the eventual destruction of
the ghiscari empire but it'll just
depend on exactly which year it is and
how much they're bending the
pre-existing Song of Ice and Fire
timeline like I said that timeline goes
back 10 to 12,000 years the timeline of
the TV show is more like 5,000 years so
like chop that in half but let me know
in the comments below
long night which big conflicts do you
want to see like do you want to see
Valerians fighting the ghiscari and
learning how to tame dragons the Andal
invasion sort of coincided with the rise
of the Valyrian freehold like that's
part of the reason why the Andals
invaded because they wanted to get the
hell out of Essos because of the
Valyrians in their dragons so I don't
think we'll be seeing too much of the
Andal invasion I think part of the real
attraction of some of these new
locations is actually seeing the
southern continent so Thoreau's because
it's supposed to be as big as Westeros
like it's enormous and there's very
little that people know about it like
even Daenerys talks about it in legends
thinking that it's inhabited by brindle
skinned people there are some ancient
cultures that were ancient even in the
time of the Valyrians that are a mystery
to people in present days there were
reports of a Valyrian named genera
bouleris that flew her dragon named
Tareq's as far south as anyone had ever
known to go in the south arose continent
in all she reported was she saw a
jungles deserts mountains after about
three years of flying her dragon around
tried to map it all she just returned
saying that it's a land without end so
they just feels like a really big
question mark for this prequel series to
explore like what is actually down there
there are a couple really cool stories
about the various empires in history in
that area trying to settle colonies in
sulfurous but all ending in complete
disaster
so during different time periods the
ghiscari first try to create settlements
there then the Valyrian freehold which
they then abandoned when they started
fighting other wars in northern Essos
that later the roy nur tried to create a
colony there but they all ended in
plague famine disease disaster because
all the various armies in history just
were not prepared for the local climate
very familiar story like army goes to a
foreign land gets all kinds of foreign
diseases and dies before they can
conquer said foreign land one of the
more interesting places down there is
actually called the Isle of toads where
there's remnants of an ancient culture
that no one knows anything about the
people appear to be fish like so imagine
fish looking people with webbed hands
and feet in Game of Thrones but I think
a lot of those ideas are just myths that
have been perverted and passed down
through history the same way that
everybody found out that Robert's
rebellion was based on a lie but at the
beginning of the story all the
characters most of
the characters not including Ned Stark
believe this something else very
different happened so the prequel series
would probably get into some of the
myths about some of these other places
that we don't spend a lot of time on the
main show but let me know in the
comments based on the way these
characters look that they've just cast
where do you think they're going to
actually be from and based on the fact
that we're going to be shooting the
pilot in the Canary Islands what'll
happen is is I have more Game of Thrones
promos to post I'll do that this weekend
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
that click here for my video for the
game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
opening scene that they posted a couple
days ago and click here for all my other
Game of Thrones Season 8 promos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight